my son I was sitting next to my son the
other day he was watching TV and he was
holding up his blanket in this ear next
in his hand next to his face to block me
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'd
be fine without me hello everybody
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua fields Millburn I am Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists in today we've got a special
guest yeah this is episode 115 and we're
gonna talk about being happier today and
we don't do interviews on the podcast
mainly because I'm not that intrigued by
interviews but occasionally we'll bring
a friend on our live events and we'll
have a little bit of a conversation but
it's our first in-studio episode with a
guest so ladies and gentlemen Dan Harris
is here with us thanks I'm a man I'm
honored thank you
well I hope I don't prove the case that
you shouldn't have guests
I just hope this doesn't turn into the
Dan Harris podcast yeah yeah that's a
danger I'm not gonna lie to you we're
open to that okay so so the reason we
don't do interviews is I'm just a bad
interviewer and so I would just ask bad
questions but so we do if I believe that
well I mean I I would say something like
hey Dan you've done cocaine cocaine
before and you meditate have you ever
meditated on cocaine
people don't typically ask that no but I
like the questions that people don't
typically add okay well we'll get to
that one hopefully but what we do is we
turn to our audience for the questions
for this podcast and so we've got some
questions from our audience today we've
got some people who called in and asked
some questions and we also got some some
lightning round questions but for those
of you who are uninformed Dan Harris is
the author of a book called 10% happier
which came out four years ago and it
totally changed my perspective on
meditation and because much like you I
was well in my 20s especially I was like
the suit-and-tie corporate guy and so
was Ryan and
I heard the word meditation and I was
allergic to it right and and then sam
harris recommended your book and I read
it and the thing that I loved about it
is it was incredibly well written and as
a memoir and and the story really like
pulled me into it but then it helped me
understand this shift in mindset that
got you to meditate so you had a bit of
a a bit of a meltdown on national TV for
those people who don't know then is the
anchor on Nightline also Good Morning
America on the weekends and you were in
front of five million people and all of
a sudden had a panic attack and that led
you to this this time of sort of
self-reflection realizing some things
needed to change and so I looked at that
book is very much a ay2 book and now you
have a new book out it's called
meditation for fidgety skeptics and it
is a how-to book that's so I love that
framing and I'm gonna steal that I'm not
going to give you any credit that's fine
we'll edit this out so you don't have it
but and I think the to complement each
other really well because you had this
there's why two side of things and I
think that's important in fact when Ryan
and I dive into minimalism you never
you'll never hear us talk about the 83
ways that you can declutter your sock
drawer because I'm less intrigued by the
how-to side of things at first because I
think you need the leverage the why two
side of things so I think the how-to is
a perfect complement once you understand
why it's important if you don't know why
it's important you might start
meditating and then you do it for a day
or two days you're like well why am I
doing this this is stupid I'm not
getting any benefit immediately my life
hasn't changed over the weekend of
meditating and all of a sudden I'm gonna
walk away from from this as opposed to
realizing why do I need to do this why
do I need to add this this clarity or or
what do I need to regain some I don't
know how you would describe but for me
meditation has been a way to calm the
chaos yeah
in a world it's not about removing
myself from the chaos and I see so many
parallels between the meditation side of
things and and minimalism if they're on
a Venn diagram I'm sure that there's a
ton of overlap but the thing that
minimalism has done for me it's not
getting away from the world of becoming
a monk or an ascetic it is allowing me
to function in a world that is
relatively chaotic by by removing that
that desire of constantly consuming and
allowing me to let go of not just the
stuff but the desire to endlessly bring
the objects into my life you know the
average human being is going to own
millions of possessions over his or her
lifetime
and average American household has 300
thousand items and of course so we have
all this chaos around us and it's not
about removing myself from that and just
becoming a peripatetic traveling monk
it's about how do I function in this
world a bit better and I think what
you've done with meditation is a way to
say okay I don't have to meditate 18
hours a day I don't have to constantly
be on retreat III need to step back and
maybe I can even enjoy meditation I
think that's the thing that your new
book outlines well is your co-author
sort of set up this exercise of how do
what wouldn't it be such a novel idea if
I enjoyed this thing called meditation
it was hard for me and it's it's still
hard for me so I think what we'd like to
do today is we've got some questions
we'll dive into it and we can we can go
in a bunch of different directions based
on these questions one of my favorite
sort of pedagogical techniques is if I
don't have a good answer to a question
we'll just answer a different question
and yeah you move around you're Robert
McNamara who had to sell the Vietnam War
to America
which was obviously a tough job used to
say that don't answer the question
you've been asked to answer the question
you wish you as yeah yeah and well and
you're in media so you you also
understand that that's sometimes people
ask you a question and they're actually
asking you a different question that's
true so what is the question behind the
yes
it's really actually very true so let's
dive into a few of these questions our
first question is from coral and Bend
Oregon
I found mentalism through your podcast
and honestly it has put a definition on
a pre-existing part of my life but I
didn't quite understand or know how to
express people think it's crazy for a
twenty something year olds not to have a
TV computer or Wi-Fi at home but now I
can just call it minimalism your podcast
is really exposed the fact that I could
be so much happier I know now that I can
make changes to be happier day to day I
don't need to feel bad for hating my
quote unquote secure job that I worked
so hard to obtain I can move to a
different city that better serves my
individual needs and I can obtain
financial freedom by eliminating my debt
the problem is the more clearly I can
see how truly happy I can be in the
future the more discontented I am today
I can't pay my debt overnight I don't
have a plan for leaving my job quite yet
I realize that even when I do find a
more fulfilling job or pay my debt off
it won't be like well that's it I
reached the summit I no longer need to
grow as an individual so what kind of
recommendations can you guys make for me
to focus on being happier today
that's a great question coral Dan's got
a great answer for this one
you know it's what's fascinating here is
I think once you put a name on something
I mean for me like I said I heard the
word meditation and same thing with with
minimalism I think minimalism was the
most perfect word and also the most
imperfect word to describe because it
conjures these sort of stark images of
white walls and owning no possessions
and and and the person who lives out of
a dumpster or a backpack or whatever and
and it can be that and I think the same
thing with meditation it can be the
Buddhist monk who does nothing but
meditate but it can also be a person who
uses it to function better and end to be
well I'm sure you get endless jokes
about being 10% happier at this point
just like and and we get the same jokes
about minimalism
it's everything we do is steeped in
irony yeah yeah everything becomes
ironic and so if if they're if you have
a moment of discontent in your life then
I assume someone's asking you how do you
become 10% happy oh yes oh yes and and
but of course the the thesis of that
first book was that 10% happier
compounds year over year over year over
year and then over the course of you
know a decade you're a hundred percent
happy or actually that's not how
compound interest works but it would be
quicker than yeah but I'm not good at
math either
anyway and I think that's the point is
is quite often we want the quick fix and
I think that's why minimalism can be
appealing at first because it's like
girl my stuff and be happy and I often
have to tell people like no that's
that's the initial bite at the Apple
that that's the thing that will that our
short answer is minimalism is the thing
that gets us past the things so we can
make room for life's most important
things which aren't things at all and
and so so I think it's the same thing
with meditation it has to do with well
and I don't think the only thing that's
gonna make coral happier here as well
you're gonna have to sit down and
meditate for an hour a day but she's
identified some some problems in her
life
and and and now she's focusing on the
problems and I think the one thing that
I would say and I'd love to hear your
thoughts on it is that she's in a place
of discomfort but it doesn't have to be
a place of discontent in fact I think
the two are often opposite I think in
fact I was just having coffee with your
wife earlier and we were talking about
the struggle and of having kids you know
before you're old you have a
three-year-old and and it's a meaningful
experience but it's also really
difficult but I think most things that
are that are uncomfortable that that
struggle lead to a particular kind of
contentment and and and I struggle
immensely I don't know if you still
struggle as much with meditation but I
still struggle with meditating it seems
like a struggle and and trying to enjoy
it
is I don't know maybe it's my analytical
brain but I am I'm at a point where I I
find that it's necessary but I I don't
necessarily enjoy it mm-hmm
so I've got this funny situation where
you've said about 15 things that I want
to respond to I'm not trying to like
line the Pennines up on the runway to
figure out let me start with coral since
I like her more than I like either me
too so corals thing is really
interesting and I think she's achieved
more of a victory that she's giving
herself credit for the well first of all
there's the victory of having latched
onto your philosophy which sort of
matched a pre-existing philosophy that
she had that she didn't have a name for
and really having a sense now of how she
wants to reorient her life that's
obviously a victory but then another
victory that I don't think she's giving
herself credit for his seeing the
discontent that is with her right now
seeing that she's living for some future
state as opposed to what's happening
right now and that is the first step
toward actually addressing it because
you you know most of us have there's
this great phrase from a writer who I
often make fun of but his name is
Eckhart Tolle he has this phrase the
background static of Perpetual
discontent that we have this it's what
the Buddhists call suffering they don't
when the Buddhists talk about suffering
the the Buddha's first his principal
pronouncement after having achieved
enlightenment whatever that is was life
is suffering it's often it's actually a
bit of a mistranslation suffering means
if you live your life only trying to get
things you want and try to avoid things
you don't want it will be inherently
unsatisfying because you live in a
chaotic impermanent universe where you
can't control much and so what she's
engaged in or what she's starting to get
in touch with is the suffering that's
involved with living for a future state
and but not being in any way happy right
now
the New Age trope that has the
unfortunate
attribute of being correct is that we
right now is all we ever get the future
she's envisioning will be experienced as
right now when it arrives and everything
that having her in the past happened
right now and so this all gets around to
me making the pitch I mix all the time
make all the time is one way to sort of
one practice that can help you get out
of living for a future state and
actually living right now and bringing
as much pleasure and joy and
satisfaction and meaning out of what's
happening right now is that meditation
it's very good for that and it is
basically this exercise for the brain
and the mind where you learn over and
over to see that you're caught in these
knots of future-oriented thinking or
jealousy or anger or planning or
whatever it is your mental hobli
hobgoblin of the moment maybe and you
can let it go and it's not magic it
doesn't work all the time but I think it
works ten percent of the time and it can
be something I think for many beginners
idiot and I would put myself as kind of
the end of the beginning because I've
been doing it for about nine years and
there's some people I mean I'm imagining
quarrel right now saying wait you're
still a beginner after nine years that's
that's disheartening yeah or that that's
right it turns me off so I don't even
want to have that encouraging me to me
though yeah because it's like being a
beginner in nine years it makes me feel
like oh it's okay I mean I think this
should be an encouraging thing for
corralejo yeah like man if you're still
a beginner in nine years it's okay that
I'm a beginner day one absolutely and
you know I won one way to think about it
is I often compare meditation to
exercise because it is exercise for your
brain absolutely and it shows up on the
brain scans mean you're changing your
brain as you do it I have been
exercising for a long time forty six
years old if it exercising since recess
right but I am never gonna play pro
sports and that doesn't stop me from
exercising and I don't need people know
there's something about some people's
approach to meditation by the way I'm
one of these people that they go they
want to win at it as if it's a win yeah
or or it's even if it's not a
competition with other people to
competition with yourself
sure and and they get into this whole
story about how their failed meditators
because the first time they sit down and
meditate they're distracted a lot that
if I handed you a flute like you
couldn't play Jethro Tull immediately
met it's meditation is a skill that you
learn over time and by the way it takes
can take you know a lifetime to get
really good at it whatever that even
mean right and I think that's the
problem is because being handed the
flute you you have sort of this outcome
and at some point you're you're whether
it's playing a sport or a musical
instrument there is an outcome where
people can sort of check the box and say
I've done this this and this and now
I've acquired the skill set and and with
meditation I think people struggle
because it's a bit nebulous I'll give
you I'll give you an outcome are you
less of an [ __ ]
and the the quite often you're not the
one that gets to quantify that's right
my wife is the sitting on the couch over
there and you I you tell me be like if I
say this correctly I think she would say
I'm less of an [ __ ] however I could
taint I retain the capacity to be a
schmuck on occasion and but it's about
that trend in the right direction and if
you're looking for a box to check that's
a great box to check yeah but I've
noticed this with you a you are a master
self deprecating you do a really good
job of well deprecating yourself to the
extent that like you I'm an [ __ ] or I
am a schmuck is the word that I'm
fidgety it's in the title of your new
book and I want I think that is one way
to humble yourself but but also if I
look at the flip side of that does does
is that also just a defense mechanism
that you throw up beforehand and and if
so does does that abdicate you from the
responsibility of just not being an
[ __ ] without without meditating no I
mean I well it may be there may be be
all sorts of subconscious
currents that feed my self deprecation
that I'm unaware of but to the extent of
wear of it I use it as a tactic for the
following reason which is I am
positioning myself as the anti guru AHA
and I've found that a very useful tactic
is to tell the truth right and it
happens to be the truth
that I'm flawed in many many hilarious
ways some of them actually not so
hilarious if you happen to be my wife
and and and what what I why I think
that's useful is that one of the great
things about meditation is not that you
conquer all of your neuroses but that
you instead in the words of a great
meditation teacher become a connoisseur
of your neuroses and if you can't have a
sense of humor in that endeavor you are
[ __ ] and that is the point ya know I
always think like the best way for me to
oh I don't know like all my
imperfections to like not let them be as
bad as as imperfections as I call them
out because if I shine light on them
then like no one else can shine light on
them and I can also like you to talk to
people how I've been able to overcome
these imperfections so yeah I think it's
great that you do that I want to talk
about if I may corals talks about
happiness and I want to get your
thoughts on this man I think that in the
Western society I mean it's written in
our Constitution we must pursue
happiness now um don't get me wrong I
love to be happy so I'm not saying that
a happiness isn't something that I like
to have but I feel like growing up in my
20s when I was in that crazy you know
corporate world working 60 70 sometimes
80 hours a week
man I was chasing happiness so much in
fact I would argue that I would actually
get it every once in a while but it was
something that was very fleeting it's
like I would get that new car and I was
happy until that first car payment or
I'd go on that vacation and it was great
until I got the credit card bill the
next month um but but I feel like
happiness is something that for me now
it's not the point happiness is
happiness again I love it and and I want
to have as much happiness as I can in my
life for me though I think living a
meaningful life is is my purpose and I
think happiness is kind of this this
byproduct
that that happens from living a
meaningful life so with coral you know
what a question I want her to ask
herself is like what does living a
meaningful life what does that mean for
her because I think that will help her
get to the happiness what do you think
man do you think happiness is too much
of a focus right now am I totally
off-base with that or well I just like
to ask you how are you defining
happiness because it's based on what I
just heard from you I suspect that
you're conflating excitement with
happiness yeah I would I would
absolutely say that for me the
definition of happiness would be some
type of elation yeah or getting what you
want
yeah or what would be some type of
excitement and that is really fleeting
yes so I so so maybe it's not maybe it's
not her chasing happiness but maybe how
she perceives happiness I think she's
like so far on her way and she's
identified the things that will make her
life more meaningful she's taking the
steps all she's I think the rut into
which she has fallen which is a minor
one and easy to get out of is that she's
so focused on achieving this Halcyon
future she's creative for herself and
she's refusing to enjoy what she has
right now she should take an enormous
amount of pride and in the reorientation
that she's undergoing and do her best to
enjoy that process which is in just
freighted with meaning but happiness
it's going to get back to that first
yeah because happiness is the root of
the word represents our cultural
ambivalence about the subject hap h AP
is the same root of the word haphazard
or hapless it means luck oh wow and so
it's basically a shitty word and it
doesn't really mean anything and the
only reason I used it in the title of my
first book was because it's the word
most of us used when we talk about
mental well-being absolutely there are
much more specific words that actually
have a higher bar form in terms of
meaning I have a higher value meaning
well-being kindness compassion patience
inner peace calm these are all
attributes that we want and as it turns
out they are trainable through
meditation well I just want to say one
other thing the best definition I've
herd of happiness whatever because I've
asked a lot of these gurus and
meditation teachers what is happiness
and I was asking this guy dr. mark
Epstein who's a great writer my Bianca
gave me a book by him that led me to
meditation actually and it was called
going to pieces without following apart
but he's written many books he I was
having dinner with him and I asked him
what's what's your definition of
happiness and he said something that was
initially very unsatisfying more of the
good and less of the bad now okay so
that sounds a little I don't know but
think about like I'm shitty at math
we've already established after I'm now
gonna use a math analogy like a geometry
analogy so if you think about a graph it
has a y-axis which runs up and down in
an x-axis which runs horizontally so in
psychology there is an this idea of a
happiness set point so which would be
the x-axis which kind of runs side to
side that good things can happen to you
so on the y-axis it would go above X in
other words your happiness would go high
but then generally it reverts to the set
point right bad things happen you go
below and then you revert to the set
point my thing of what happens with
meditation is that the top of that graph
the good stuff gets higher and more
sustained because you are enjoying the
good things that happen to you and you
aren't rushing off to the next hit of
dopamine as you were doing in your 20s
with the car and then the car payment
etc etc and then the lower end of the of
the graph the bad stand when bad things
happen to you gets shallower because
you're not engaging in so much useless
rumination and you're able to recover
more quickly and then I would say
simultaneously that the happiness set
point itself the x-axis goes up that is
more of the good and less of the bad and
that is a workable serviceable
definition of happiness for me yeah
absolutely no and I think the word happy
that you use in your book I think it was
the perfect word because your book
doesn't say here's how to be happy
it's here's how to be 10% happier and
and with that it takes a lot of work for
sure so no I agree coral is on the right
path she needs to keep up the hard work
but yeah maybe something like meditation
could totally help her take a minute and
realize that what she does have maybe
she could be happy with and also help
her
- - I look forward to what she has
coming down the road fool give herself a
pat on the back for what she's done all
right absolutely actually quite towering
well I think that's the other thing I
mean there's this old cliche right about
about gratitude and and we hear all of
these these sort of trite sayings about
gratitude and they've been turned into
success arees posters or whatever but I
think the truth is we are what we focus
on and and if we're focusing on the
moment on what we don't have I mean that
that seems to always be the thing Ryan
and I wrote this essay a few years ago
about Christmas it was called the worst
Christmas ever and there's this this kid
and the story was based off of a real
event to happen that this kid is going
through his Christmas presents and
opened them all up and really happy in
the moment right like a static pleasure
in that one moment they discards the toy
moves on to the next thing and the by
the end of opening his 10 or 12 presents
he didn't get the one present that he
wanted he wanted this you know a Optimus
Prime thing or whatever and that's the
only thing that he was focused on so
they like he was overcome with
discontent even though a moment ago he
had you know sort of 12 spikes on on the
the the dopamine seismograph or whatever
like he he had all of he had all of the
happiness in the moment but it was
absolutely fleeting and it really had to
do with what he was focused on and in
the moment now his excuses he doesn't
have a fully developed preclinical
prefrontal cortex but but we don't have
this normal parents and and and the
truth is that like we do the same thing
it's just on a much grander scale and
that's what the Buddha was talking I
want to talk about suffering yeah that
if your whole life is oriented around
getting what you think you want the
pleasure won't last and and if you think
that you're gonna permanently avoid the
unpleasant I've got some bad news for
you and so can you achieve equanimity in
the face of whatever it is arises that
is what you that is the skill one of the
skills you're training in meditation
it's time again it's not
magic it can be hard to do but it is
worthwhile endeavor my view can I just
address those what you were saying about
enjoyment yes because I don't want to
let that pass when I say that is one of
the planes I want to get off the runway
from before because it's really
important and I want I want to hear a
little bit more from you but your
meditation practice when you say that
you're not enjoying it what do you mean
by that
I find that but there's there's this old
saying that writers don't like writing
they like having written yes so I feel
that way I don't I actually I'm one of
the few writers who enjoys the process
more than the art of that man I am so
jealous well it's the same thing with
meditation it's a flip flop to here
right where where for me in the moment
like I do feel on a static pleasure
probably 50% of the time the other 50%
of the time I want to put my head
through a wall because writing is really
hard but eventually gets a point where
there's something that is is good and
and rewarding in a way that that nothing
else is rewarding for me and I assume
there's that place in meditation I just
haven't gotten there yet I'm still and
so I teach a writing class and and the
thing that I tell students is when you
first start 80% of the time you're gonna
want to put your head through a wall
yeah and eventually after enough writing
it's gonna be 70 percent of the time but
they're still gonna be 7 out of 10 days
they're gonna be bad days for you and it
gets better and I don't think it ever
gets better than 50/50 with respect to
writing and I don't know if that those
numbers feel right to you for meditation
but I haven't gotten past the 8020 it's
right where I still do the meditation
and I have some things that help me that
help me through the process I like to
meditate in asana and it sort of
facilitates focus in a way that like it
sort of forces my mind to to calm down
but or maybe in a deprivation tank but I
found that that for me it's it's still
hard to enjoy yeah I can just sit there
and it's like just you're and then I get
mad at myself for not enjoying it right
and that that goes back to the
competition thing like I'm compete
myself okay so I hear so much in what
you're saying and by the way while I'm
about to offer you some Corrections I
don't want you to think there's any
judgment in it because I have fallen
prey to the exact same psychology that
you are describing so just know brothers
from another mother
but the prot the I'm hearing and you're
thinking and you should jump in if I've
misheard you
the most noxious thing you can bring to
the meditation party is expectation you
are wanting to feel a certain way and
desire way back to the days of the
Buddha is a classic hindrance to
meditation
it's a weird video game where you can't
make progress if you want to make
progress and so actually the the
attitude to bring to meditation is it it
doesn't matter what I'm feeling the only
game is to see whatever I'm feeling
clearly why because when you see your
inner chaos clearly it doesn't own you
and so it doesn't matter if you sit down
and you're totally distracted you have
to start over and over and over again
that's actually a good set because
you're seeing your distraction when you
see your distraction that is a victory
and it's a victory of real consequence
what's the consequence the consequences
you are seeing clearly your inner
cacophony and that cacophony has less
purchase over your actions and so if you
sit and you're overcome by restlessness
sadness anger doubt about doubt isn't
them one of the most insidious things in
meditation which is this am i doing it
right is it worth it bla bla bla then
and if you see it clearly and just go
back to your point of focus which is
usually your breath that is meditation
and it doesn't matter what you feel
because you're getting to a special
state is irrelevant you're building a
skill here and the skill is mindfulness
which is just the ability to see what's
happening in your mind and in a given
moment without getting carried away by
it and so the the content of what you're
seeing is irrelevant to the skill your
training and when you approach
meditation that way the world's your
oyster it's funny man because I was
thinking when you were talking about
your meditation practice I'm like I
don't want to even talk about my
meditation practice because it really
hasn't changed much
from when we talked to you last doesn't
matter on your podcast matter and it's
made me feel so much better about it
yeah because you should because honestly
like I it does a lot for me I can
totally tell the difference but I go
into it with no expectations that's
beautiful and I'm like you know what I
have a half hour right now and if I can
only concentrate for a minute then
that's what all this is why you're the
more popular minimalist that's not true
I'm just trying to foment yeah you guys
always act like you like each other so
much even we're like off-camera but can
they really like each other
can I Drive away you I should be the
most popular minimal choral thank
surprised I get you right did I get you
right you're you're spot-on
okay the two words I thought about
before this was expectation and there
was another desire X word that really
really stood out that I'm blanking on
I'm sure will come back but coral real
quick I want to send you a copy of both
the Dan's books then you probably notice
we bought a case of your 10 person happy
or a while ago we often handed out the
friend oh wow family member isn't thank
you i autographed and says from you not
autograph that book you gave me
it's an autograph maybe there's an
autograph okay right I found some guy
named Dan anyway I'd love to see a copy
of both of Dan's books a 10-person
happier and meditation for fidgety
skeptics will have Sean reach out to you
coral and send you both of those our
next question is from Lucinda in Sydney
Australia I'm just getting ready to go
on a trip and I've had this heart is got
got kicking gut-wrenching moment where I
realized I've minimized a wallet that
contained a fair bit of cash I'm just
one and you know feeling the kind of
feeling up I'm going to is I my goodness
I shouldn't have been so Restless in my
minimizing I'm just wondering if either
of you guys have had that experience and
what helped you
just let it go because I guess what's
done is done and there's not much I can
do about it now but yeah I found the
kind of maybe set of mentally unwinding
weather minimizing stuff was a great
idea when you make stupid mistakes like
that so Dan she's asking about this this
wallet and had cash in it and we were
just talking about desire and we were
talking about expectations but there's
another feeling that's in there and
that's that the feeling of regret and
letting go of something and then and
then regretting it or or taking some
sort of action and then regretting it I
don't know if you can if you can talk
about how meditation has helped out with
with regret or obviously it's helped you
let go the same way that that minimalism
has helped us like though physical
things it
I think meditation quite often helps us
let go of of these internal things yes
definitely so the the Buddhists have
this idea of the middle way and and by
the way when I talk about Buddhism I
can't believe by the way that I'm a dude
like regularly talks about Buddhism you
not what I would have predicted for
myself when I talk about it I'm gonna
talk about it from a religious
perspective I'm talking about it as a
set of practices and a philosophy that
happens to be in my view brilliant so
the middle way is that we tend to
approach most things in our lives like
from a binary standpoint like Pleasant
or unpleasant happy or sad and sunny or
cloudy but actually generally speaking
there's a lot of nuance so when you're
dealing with things that you've done
that you feel badly about the two
options that are usually on the table
for people are denial or flagrant self
laceration but actually there is there
is this option that the Buddhists talk
about of wise remorse mm-hmm I think
actually there's something to look at it
maybe she was loosened to write she was
perhaps a little bit heedless maybe in
her minimizing she was excited about it
and she took it perhaps a little too far
it's worth reflecting on that it is not
however worth going into a spiral of
shame out of which she has trouble
pulling herself and and again meditation
is useful for this on two levels one is
what I just discussed sort of the
Buddhist philosophy of being aware that
there is such a thing as sort of wise
remorse that allows you to examine your
behavior without you know like getting
suicidal where meditation as a practice
is useful is it boosts your self
awareness so that you can see when
you've crossed the line between wise
remorse and useless self-recrimination
mm-hmm so when I when I look at her I
think of this there was a time a few
years ago where now I'm a minimalist I
don't know a whole lot of clothes right
although I like the jacket you were
wearing when I saw you this morning
Montclair yeah it's a high-class minimal
oh you did know I'm just gonna say you
know being a minimalist you have to have
really nice hair yeah and you have to
have really nice clothes just not a lot
of them and well I so I didn't have a
whole lot of clothes but I was going to
wash them and you get in the cycle of
everyday life you know how to do this
chore you're about to do whether it's
washing dishes or doing the laundry and
I go to do the laundry and I put all my
clothes all my my dark clothes in the
washing machine I put the detergent in
there and then of course I start pouring
the bleach in there is all the clothes
that I own functionally and realize that
as I'm pouring the bleach in there oh
[ __ ]
and and in that moment I'm like oh I've
obviously done something that is wrong
and there's a feeling of regret and I
think what you're saying there's that
feeling is good because hopefully what
it's going to get me to do in the future
and in the present is to pay closer
attention yes even to those relatively
mundane tasks and I can tell you there
are a few times even last week where I
caught myself almost doing that again
and it allowed me to like reset me oh
yeah I remember you did that one thing I
felt that pain I don't want to
experience that pain again
because you know I had to go back out
and and and buy my my shirts and pants
and all this other stuff because I had
ruined basically all of my clothes and I
think it's the same thing as yeah you're
not gonna get that back and how how
useful it is it to sit at home and worry
about the money that you lost by giving
that away in fact you probably giving up
more time worrying about the thing then
you you can actually earn that money
back with that same time doing something
positive what there's something useful
to be learned about how to go about
minimizing in a way that's a little bit
more mindful same thing with doing the
laundry that's in a little bit more
mindful but but where's where do you
draw the line and I think the
self-awareness that comes with
meditation can be useful there Lucinda
congratulations you screwed up we all
screw up and what you do when you screw
up is what Dan said you take note of
that and you learn from it and if
there's listeners out there they can
learn from it too
number one guy at our event who came and
he was like you know I was minimizing
but my my wife and kids they keep asking
me where stuff is and I look at him oh
my gosh sorry I got rid of that home Oh
what do I do do you remember we were
just like dude you have to have a better
plan when you put my stuff I think
that's the thing is we get really
excited about when we take on a new task
and I don't I don't know if you find
this in meditation to me sometimes
people dive into the deep end and they
get in trouble if people go on a 10-day
retreat and they've never meditated
before you might go to a pretty dark
place that that is hard to come back
from or you just might be so turned off
by the experience you don't ever want to
do it again I think it's same thing with
minimalism we had a family of
Philadelphia who rented a dumpster and
threw all their stuff in it and their
house caught fire that cuz it was a
dumpster fire and thankfully they've
realized like the the error of their
ways but I could see how that that would
turn someone all from ever wanting to
let go of something ever again yeah I
assume you did attend a retreat recently
yeah I just got back for one this is
your second or third fourth holy moley
yeah so there was a world champion
meditator trust me
there are people are way more baller
than me way way way but you know it's
true that in some cases if you
meditation does actually throw you into
a tough space it's pretty rare from what
I can tell but if you know what I would
say to anybody
who has real psychological trauma in
their past and is that if you want to
meditate that you should do it under
professional supervision you should talk
to your mental health provider before
you do it for most people however even
if you went on a 10-day retreat as your
first move well I think that would
probably be jarring I actually don't
think it would necessarily throw you
into a dark place but and also turn you
off and they turn you well that's the
other thing that all fours is yeah I
don't think I don't think Lucinda here
is gonna be like well I don't I got rid
of one wall I don't ever want to get rid
of anything else again but I could see
how it would turn her off from from
wanting to let go and letting go of the
physical things is somewhat of a a
metaphor for just letting go in general
yeah no I totally agree
just ruminating in this loss is going to
do her way more harm than good what you
were talking about really reminded me of
how you kind of talked about this
selfless or this useless self rumination
in our documentary and that has stuck
with me ever since Matt did that
interview with you so Lucinda you have
mourned your loss and it's gone it is a
sunk cost at this point that was one of
the biggest lake just lessons I helped
get me through everything when we were
going through our minimalist journeys
even today it still helps me when I look
at something I'm like man I really hate
to to let that go but sometimes you got
to look at something like a son cause
horrified you know if I lost something I
have definitely lost money before and it
hurts but worrying about it is not gonna
bring it back the only thing you can do
is really plan better the next time you
you get rid of stuff Lucinda so again
congratulations learn from your mistake
and and move on Lucinda I'd love to send
you a copy of our book it's called
essential it's 12 different chapters 150
different essays about living a more
intentional life there's one chapter in
there on mindfulness and that bleach
story I just told I wrote an essay about
it about spilling bleach on all of my
clothes and also since you're in Sydney
we're headed over to Australia and March
we're ending the less is now tour in
Australia we're going to be in seven
cities over there in March Sydney
Melbourne Brisbane Perth Auckland New
Zealand and
Adelaide and oh we're going back to
Melbourne we got a second show there so
Shawn if you would reach out to her give
her a couple tickets to that event love
to see you there
I kind of want your life oh man I wish
we were going to Rogen tomorrow yeah we
can trade man yeah no kidding that's
pretty great all right well let's see
here oh yeah we'd love to hear what you
all have to say so if you're listening
to this and you have a comment or tip
about happiness or meditation including
any advice for any of our callers today
leave us a voicemail for zero six two
one nine seven eight three nine you can
also email a voice memo right from your
phone to podcast at the minimalists comm
it's my favorite part of the show at the
end of each show we air our favorite
comments and tips from our listeners
Ryan what time is this you know what
time it is it is time for our lightning
round where we answer questions from
social media so Dan what we do is we
take a couple questions from social
media we try to get some tweetable sized
answers in there we might ramble just a
little bit before we get to the answer
but but yeah feel free to jump in metal
but no pressure all right all right we
are on Twitter Facebook and Instagram at
the minimalists and as Ryan said this is
where we do our best to answer answer
each question with a short shareable
less than hundred and forty character
response although I'm told it's 280
characters now so let's look at still
keep it to 140 yeah so we call these
minimal Maxim's and so feel free to
inject some sort of Zen Cohen okay that
will will tidally wrap up the the
answers here our first question Ryan all
right our first question is from
Christopher Christopher says I love it
when I meditate I clearly see the
benefits of meditation I consume
everything I possibly can about it
podcasts books apps etc but I still find
it difficult to actually stop and
practice any tips to just get her done
is that like is that a Cable Guy
reference yeah nice
so my short answer my short answer would
be and so I practiced this this morning
in fact prime the pump start each day
with a small victory I find for me that
meditation works best instead of like
trying to to wait and postpone Isleta
day same thing with exercise so for me
if I if I have a few small victories set
up my day I feel like the the the pump
has been primed for other bigger
successes throughout the day really good
my answer is pretty simple better to
have spent a minute meditating than
tweeting now no no the irony does not
escape me that this is going to be a
tweet but they asked for our advice so
it's a little bit different I would say
one minute counts and it I would just
say kind of a version of what both of
you said now let me get it down to 140
characters
one minute counts one min example yeah
one leg count that's perfect man when it
comes to meditation one minute counts up
so Shawn puts all the the Shawn's on
here today's coming out to California
today we're actually so we're building a
podcast in film studio here in Los
Angeles and right now we are in the
palatial estate of Matt D Avella we're
in his kitchen at his kitchen table yes
at the top of the Hollywood Hills
no I'm just kidding and and and so yeah
Shawn will put all of our pithy answers
in the show notes what's our next
question right our next question is from
Sam wise how do you maintain happiness
and contentment without becoming
complacent and stopping moving forward
so so my pithy answer to this one is
complacency is not the birthplace of
contentment and and I think quite often
like that's what we're searching for
them we were talking to coral earlier
it's like once I get to this magical
place if I have the ideal couch and the
ideal painting on the wall and this is
wrong inherently wrong with any of these
things in fact I would argue that many
of these things add a particular flavor
to life that make it more enjoyable
right so I'm not against owning things
it's about owning the right things but
we try to get this ideal place of
comfort and then wonder why we're
miserable there's a director Tom Shadyac
he he had that documentary come out
called I am yes and so he was sort of in
this place where he had achieved that
level of extreme comfort and and was
totally miserable because of it and and
so he because you think you're going to
get there and that's the the thing about
a horizon once you reach the horizon
there's always another horizon oh that's
pithy to Sean you can put that in the
notes man after talking to you earlier I
kind of want to rethink my answer here
but what I've written down here is
happiness is ephemeral living a
meaningful life brings lasting rewards
but you know now I kind of wanted the
pen that because I think the question
you asked about the definition of
happiness I don't know I've never asked
that before I just assumed everyone had
the same definition of you have that
feeling of elation where you know
nothing could really bring you down I
guess maybe there are different levels
of that elation but I also know that if
you wake up every single morning elated
like that you're probably a manic person
you you have both talked really openly
about about certain drug addictions and
in the past and I think we when we try
to achieve it doesn't have to be through
drugs it can be through achievement
accomplishments quote success we we
create this new baseline that XY axis
you were talking about earlier where
we're the new baseline is I have to get
up and and take these pills or do blow
or whatever just to to get back to
normal we're the new that were the thing
that was high has to be the new normal
and and I think there's a difference in
reaching that in a way that is unnatural
though the quick fix the taking the pill
route and the the hard work the non
complacency of meditation although it
can seem complacent at times right when
you you when I think of meditation I
think of the the the world series of
meditation with it with the you know the
the Buddhists and in a and some sort of
ashram somewhere or whatever
I think I'm conflating religions there
but I
I imagine like extreme complacency I
think even in my 20s I would have looked
at those guys like what a bunch of beta
males or whatever right like what are
they doing
well beam I think in part that's because
meditation as I like to say has been the
victim of the worst marketing campaign
for anything ever
and and the imagery traditional imagery
of our meditation is like a dude in
loincloth on the Himalayan mountain top
and floating off into a bubble of bliss
but that isn't actually what it is it's
exercise for your brain and that's why
high achieving folks if you know at
corporations in the military in
entertainment and athletics are doing
this thing because it makes you more
focused and less yanked around by your
emotions which can have a really
salutary effect on your professional
life the I think the that I don't know
if I'll say anything tweetable here but
the this the mistake that the Twitter
question is that is embedded in that
question is to conflate happy happiness
and complacency and that they're not the
same thing and you know just because you
start to this is a very common concern
and I certainly had it too when I was
getting into meditation because my dad's
motto as the price of security is
insecurity and I really believe that and
you know what I still believe it in
anyways that's the tweetable answer it's
the price of security is insecurity
because actually if you want to do
anything great a certain amount of
stress and plotting and planning and and
worrying is part of the deal risk bridge
which is in here yes insecurity yes but
but that doesn't you know you it doesn't
mean that what we tend to do is to take
to make our stress worse than it needs
to be and the through the self-awareness
you generate through meditation through
mindfulness you can see when you've
crossed the line between useless worry
and what I call constructive anguish and
that is that's the money because you
want to have a certain amount of stress
but you don't have so much stress that
you wear down your resiliency or
effectiveness or focus so it's a tough
balance and meditation can be very
I love that man because there I think
someone told me a long time ago in the
corporate world I think they were
probably not right in this sense but
what they said stuck with me and there
was one point where I'm you know 80 hour
week and I'm stressing and one of my
co-workers looks at me and he goes you
know stress some stress is good he's
right and I totally agree or she's right
whoever yeah no it was a guy I mean I
either way though um yeah my point is is
that I think again they were wrong in
that situation cuz i was i was wearing
down yeah um and I felt myself wearing
down but I don't try to avoid all stress
in my life I don't think you can or
should and I don't think if your work I
don't think people should be worried
that if they meditate they're gonna lose
their edge I think what meditation gives
you is boost boosted focus lowered
emotional reactivity how can either of
those things hurt well speaking of
things that hurt I think that that I've
had this love-hate relationship with
competition whether it's competition
with myself or competition with others
and I was we were living in Montana for
the last five years I was doing a sauna
with with there's an American Indian
tribe up there and one of the guys said
something that really resonated with me
and I don't know that it's true 100% of
the time but he said we look at
competition as mental illness and he
goes because if you lose I also lose and
if I win then you win or if you win I
win and that's how we look at it as our
tribe it's a collective sort of winning
and I think it's the same thing what
you're talking about there I think I
think there's probably this middle way
where there is a level of competition
that is truly toxic where it where it is
damaging to our personal and
professional lives but I think there's
also a useful amount you know they're
sort of the friendly competition yeah
but look at that we're all podcasters
here right so it's useful for me to look
around at whose podcast does really well
what can I learn from them that is the
upside of competition yeah
the downside is if I'm walking around
rooting for my fellow podcast hosts to
fail or or worse like you're looking
down on yourself because you're not
doing as well oh that's right as your
other I certainly
I do do a little bit of that well you
what but I shouldn't and it's useful to
see all right we have time for one
overtime question we do something each
week on patreon where we record a
overtime bonus episode it's called the
minimalists private podcast and you can
get it right there on your regular
podcast feed it shows up as a separate
podcast and we do this each week for our
patreon supporters because we don't do
advertisements because advertisements
suck and so we've decided to make this
podcast 100 percent advertisement free
100 percent listener supported and so
we'll hop on over and do this overtime
question from Katy here's what we're
gonna answer from Katy here at a moment
she says what is your best advice for
first-time meditators and then we have
several other similar questions to that
so we we're gonna hop on over to this
overtime question we'll be right back to
the regular podcast by the way if you
all want to listen to that bonus episode
we just recorded you can on over to the
minimalists com click on donate at the
top they're a bunch of different ways to
support this podcast one final question
for you before we move on to our segment
called right here right now
have you ever tried to meditate on
cocaine dan you're gonna ask that
question no because by the time I quit
doing cocaine I'm sorry I I start I
discovered meditation years after I quit
doing cocaine uh-huh yeah just thrown it
out there yeah I'm sure it's been done
quite the part yeah maybe maybe there's
like a listener out there who can call
in with a tip or trick four zero six two
one nine seven eight three nine all
right let's move on to right here right
now so we talked about what's going on
in the lives of the minimalist and I'd
like to just talk to to dan real quick
and encourage you all to check out three
things from him you could well at least
two for sure his new book is called
meditation for fidgety skeptics it's the
how-to side of meditating if you are
unfamiliar with where to get started I
think it's a great place to go there's
also a journey in there and then you
talk about your wife and sort of her her
aversion to to meditation and then also
learning to enjoy
as well and the the very how-to steps
which weren't covered as much in your
first book 10% happier which I also
encourage people to check out there's
sort of a an addendum there on how to
meditate but then also you have an app
it's called the 10% happier app and I
could tell you my partner
Rebecca it's the only app that's ever
worked for her for her meditation Wow
and so she still uses it daily that's
really I don't know if it's the video
base side of things we've also audio on
there as well but but there are some
tools there that have helped her that
she couldn't find elsewhere it's really
great and so if you're looking for a
great app to get started
it's called 10-person happier you can
find that wherever you get apps and then
last but not least you have a podcast
called 10% happier I've interviewed
these jokers called the minimalist so
Nightline which was really cool that
aired recently that was out just I think
last month yeah that was great wrapping
up I got a really good response to that
yes and I know I've said this to you
before but it's worth saying here I was
talking about Diavel about this before
that that the single the the media
appearance that has generated them the
highest number of people stopping me on
the street was your film love and Sam
Harris who's also we're not related but
we're friends who's also in the film has
said the same thing that when that thing
hit over the holidays a couple of
holiday seasons ago it was like my
twitter feed and people stopping me in
airports and people set you up dude I
got it you have no idea and Sam for that
matter has no idea what you've done for
us
so the fact that we could do that for
you man like that that really means a
lot I'm glad we could do that man that's
that's awesome and it was really it was
awesome speaking of documentaries back
to right here right now Ryan and I are
filming our next documentary I heard and
so we're doing it in front of a live
audience on February 10th if you're in
the Los Angeles area we're doing two
tapings the 3:00 p.m. is already sold
out but there are a few tickets left for
the 7 p.m. show it's it's basically a
follow-up to our Netflix documentary
eight minimalism and it's called the
minimalists les is now so Ryan and I
over the last year we went around the
u.s. and Canada next is Australia and
we've given this this talk about
living a meaningful life with less and
so we're gonna do is we're finally gonna
capture it on on film in this beautiful
warehouse space in Los Angeles and I
want to invite all of you to attend so
it's basically this film is going to
combine the the in-depth talk about
minimalism that the Ryan and I give
we're gonna build a documentary around
around that talk and sort of go into
it's different from the documentary
minimalism because we scratch a surface
on a bunch of different topics in that
we're gonna dive really deep on sort of
the the events that got Ryan and and me
over to this thing called minimalism and
living more intentionally being these
suit-and-tie corporate guys and sort of
walking away from that and so that is
the documentary they're working on next
you can find the details that over our
website the minimalists comm just click
on our tour page there it's February
10th and oh this Friday also on patreon
so if you're one of our patreon
supporters we recorded a live tour stop
with our friend Colin right he's the
Peripatetic minimalist traveler he
travels to a new country over four
months carrying with him everything he
owns we did a live event with him in
Detroit we're gonna release that
exclusively for our patreon supporters
so head on over to patreon comm slash
the minimalists and that's all I got
Ryan dude you're not gonna tell him
you're not gonna tell her patreon
supporters about about what we've done
with their money yeah dude we totally
got a new office we did well yeah so
we're moving into the I was I was in
Montana and Josh sent me pictures I was
I was really really excited to come back
sorry go ahead
so we're working on this new studio
space and it's the reason we moved out
here is to do the we want to do a lot
more things with film and and so we
found that because the documentary came
out so it resonated with so many people
it we had found we had pockets people
who read our books people who read the
blog people who listened to the podcast
but the other way that we hadn't
communicated was visually that way with
the documentary and then also doing
other types of video as well so web
series or YouTube videos in many
documentaries a lot of different things
you can do is video as you know with
with all the TV stuff that you've done
and and realizing like that is our next
foray into bringing this message into
more people's homes and ears and eyes is
is to do this podcast of film studios
yeah we just found a space
beautiful space like yeah I haven't been
there yet I'm gonna go there later today
and check it out but yeah I just want to
say thanks to all the patreon supporters
each and every one of you like it it
really helped us do this and it's a
beautiful building and if it wasn't for
you we wouldn't be able to do it so Josh
and I really look forward to providing
some awesome content content I said it
oh my god
fire me we are looking forward to
creating some awesome things for you
Josh and I do not do content we try to
focus on meaningful creation so we're
really looking forward to that then
anything that we want to leave the
people with I want you two guys to come
on my podcast man the documentary comes
out it sounds great yeah so I want you
to I would love for that to happen also
just in terms of leaving people with
something I would just say don't beat
yourself up about getting distracted you
can't hear it enough well you can't be a
bad meditator
the only bad meditator is somebody who
doesn't meditate that's tweetable hmm
and so just just do it even if it's just
for a minute it will make a difference
and if I'm wrong send me a note on
Twitter and tell me I'm a [ __ ] you ever
had anyone tweet in say that people tell
me I'm a [ __ ] all the time oh yeah
never who never for that but we're okay
he's at Danby Harris on on Twitter you
can find all the stuff Tim Burton
happier calm yes yeah and check out his
new book check out everything from Dan
got anything else for us right no man
I'm just we glad we could have danger to
outshine us on this part yes highly
doubt that thank you very much really
appreciate thanks for being here are
some comments and tips from our
listeners hello my name is Erika from
Ohio a vegan woman at a life event in
December asked about her dilemma when
choosing to buy plastic vegan clothing
products versus leather ones she was
concerned that leather products are not
as sustainable as weather ones because
they wear out faster and I'm calling in
with some advice to help extend the
shelf life of your products so they
don't go into the landfill before their
time I only own one pair of black pooped
boots that have survived six brutal Ohio
winters so far by following these three
steps one if you have access to a
waterproofing agent
apply it liberally to if you live where
it snows and salt accumulates on your
boots wipe the salt off with a wet rag
or cloth when you get home and three if
your zipper starts nagging wd-40 is your
best friend if you still like leather
better look into a secondhand market hi
this is Mike from Rochester I'm calling
in response to a question that Stephanie
from Georgia posed in the one of your
recent podcasts in Georgia she was
trying to sound like rasterize her love
of shopping or her enjoyment of shopping
my response and something I've kind of
come up for myself is instead of buying
an excess buying to replace so if you
want to buy a new if you find a shirt
that's better than your current or you
find a piece of furniture that's better
than your current piece of furniture
that will coincide with your your values
as well as your finances so you'll keep
what you've determined to be a
reasonable amount of stuff and within
your ear means to to pay forward and
afford a financial hurry my name is
Katie from Sioux Falls South Dakota and
my tip is for theresa from the phoenix
podcast she was having trouble with
getting rid of some of them with
mementos from her dad I was really close
with my grandma who passed away probably
about 12 years ago and I ended up with a
lot of her jewelry because that was what
I played with that as a kid and as I've
gone through my minimizing journey I've
decided to keep one thing and it's her
class ring from 1948 I wear it every day
in fact I it's too small now I can't
even take it off and everything else I
have let go and that way I can always
keep her with me however I don't have
the burden of all of her other jewelry
all right Joe that's it for this episode
if you have a question for the
minimalists give us a call for zero six
two one nine seven eight three nine you
can also send a voice memo right from
your phone to podcast at the minimalists
comm and if you leave here with just one
message we hope it's this love people
and use things because the opposite
never were
thanks for listening y'all see you next
time
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green oh I bet that you'll
be fine without
[Music]
every little thing that you got Han
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for and you got a grand oh I
bet that you'll be fine without you
so chair your eyes or tea
[Music]
you